what's going on guys this is rob and
sony may have inadvertently just spoiled
the ending of
spider-man 3
in the events of doctor strange 2. okay
so here's the thing i was hit up by a
fan on twitter and they said hey man
have you checked the oz corp industries
website recently and and i was
i had no idea what they were talking
about
and they sent me screenshots and then i
remembered not a lot of you guys recall
back during the andrew garfield
spider-man films sony went on a viral
thing right where they were doing like
all this viral information and stuff
like that in an effort to drum up
interest from the movies one of the
things they done is that he created an
oscorp industry website it was basically
designed to mirror what you would see if
oscorp industries exist in the real
world right part of the online viral
campaign
the website's still up
and
there's a huge revelation there but
before we get into that we need to
actually address something right so it's
entirely possible this website's fake
and here's the reason why i say that the
original os corp industry website url
was oscorp industries.com this one is
oscorp industries.com so it's entirely
possible it's fake or it could be that
it was designed that way because now
it's oscorp in a different universe
therefore a different company url right
in the same way that the venom woke up
in a new reality and the hotel was
occupied by somebody else i don't know
whatever kind of logic you want to use
so that's one thing we do need to
acknowledge it is entirely possible that
it's fake having acknowledged that let's
let our imaginations run wild so here's
the thing about this man
[Laughter]
if this is true if this is true it
changes everything why because it says
that oscorp industries is now in a joint
venture with stark industries that
they're basically partnering and they're
working together did oscorp industries
buy historic industries i don't really
know it doesn't really matter here's the
thing odds corp industries if it does
exist in the mcu this changes a few
things one we basically know that at the
very least green goblin norman osborne
they will basically stay in the marvel
cinematic universe so this may be a part
of the deal that was worked out between
sony and marvel not too long ago here's
the reason why i say that when you look
at the sony solo spider-man films while
i will say that like some of the other
movies made more money different things
like that the tom holland movies are the
ones that we seem to enjoy the most why
because tom holland is in the mcu
because you get to see spider-man doing
his own thing but then you get to see
him fight alongside the avengers and one
of the things that sony and marvel had
to have come to the conclusion with
specifically as it related to allowing
marvel to use tom holland in the mcu is
that they are greater than the sum of
their parts that sony and marvel studios
working in unison brings a much better
product for the fans and we're more
likely to watch it more times thus
generating more money for them than if
they do it on their own if you never see
spider-man in the mcu and you only see
him in sony films and so i'd have to
believe this would be a continuation of
what they've been doing that the sony
multiverse isn't so much its own
multiverse as it is or at least was at
one point and is now being merged with
the marvel cinematic universe to create
one singular cohesive universe in terms
of rights and all that kind of stuff i
don't know right sony probably keeps on
making spider-man movies they keep all
the money from that marvel keeps
everything else and spider-man appears
it right i have no idea that's gonna be
the case the important thing here is
that with this revelation it would
solidify that not only does the green
goblin stay in the mcu but seemingly
almost any of the other villains but
here's the best thing about this right
it has nothing to do with spider-man the
significance of norman osborn and oscorp
being in the mcu has nothing to do with
peter parker at least not as far as i'm
concerned has nothing to do with him why
let's turn to marvel comics for a second
and talk about something called the
ultimate
universe which we've talked about before
but the ultimate universe was basically
an answer to the question in the year
2000 what if superheroes came into
existence today what would they look
like right ultimate spider-man was
basically the one that spearheaded that
is the reason why the ultimate universe
became as popular as it was but in the
ultimate universe line of comics peter
parker received his powers from a bite
from a radioactive spider that was
created by ozcorp using something called
the oz formula what was the odds formula
the oz formula was oscorp's attempt to
duplicate the super soldier serum that
gave captain america his powers
technically it was nick fury then it was
steve rogers and then oscar tried to
copy it but different history when it
comes to the ultimate universe the
important thing here is that they were
trying to find a way to duplicate the
super soldier serum the oz formula was
the closest they got to it one of the
spiders bit peter parker peter parker
went on to become spider-man here's the
funny thing the spiders of the oz
formula bit one other person
and his name
was miles morales now that's the cool
thing here man that's the cool thing
here bear with me here for a second
right because i feel like some of you
guys are like man no no bear with me
here right bear with me here miles
morales spider-man in the mcu spider-man
right this is gonna be cool there's a
couple ways that we can kind of know
that this is effectively going to happen
or most likely will happen the first is
just the nature of the plot for
spider-man 3. i love the idea of seeing
like toby mcguire and andrew garfield
and tom holland all teaming up in a
singular movie and fighting against
whatever villains they happen to face
off against regardless of however long
toby mcguire and andrew garfield are in
the movie for right it might be 15
minutes it could be like 100 minutes we
have no real idea how long they're gonna
be in it the important thing here is
that it's cool to see those guys team up
but wouldn't it be cool if that was just
kind of a way to sort of train us right
to get us introduced and acclimated to
the idea of two different spider-men
existing in the same movie franchise the
same universe on the same earth together
wouldn't that be cool because if you got
miles morales that's basically what
would happen unless
they killed peter parker
wouldn't it be crazy if like the opening
scene from spider-man into the
spider-verse where like peter parker
dies is actually how tom holland dies
they just didn't tell us that was the
case wouldn't that be nuts there's no
evidence whatsoever to suggest that's
the case
and in fact the way he died flies in the
face of seemingly everything we know
about tom holland but it would be cool
if it happened but i digress the thing
about this is that having miles morales
in the mcu it's basically already there
right we know from spider-man homecoming
that like donald glover basically played
uncle aaron he made a reference to his
nephew we never actually got his name
but if you're familiar with the comics
the nephew of uncle aaron is miles
morales and so again it'd be a cool
concept to see that happen the other
part of this is that if oscorp and stark
industries are really working together
the website starts talking about things
like neurogenics right like biological
engineering things along those lines now
one of the worst kept secrets in the
history of the mcu has been continued
attempts to find a way to duplicate the
super soldier serum right that was the
plot of falcon in the winter soldier
that john walker us agent is basically
the next person to receive what we would
call the super soldier serum of steve
rogers of captain america so we know it
can be duplicated now whether or not
oscorp got their hands on it i probably
doubt it that would seem to fly in the
face of the purpose of creating the
oscorp formula anyway why would you try
to duplicate the super soldier serum
when you already have it in your
possession
the serum itself had basically been
destroyed in falcon in the winter
soldier by john walker's seemingly the
only person walking around that has that
serum at his disposal and so because of
that it would make perfect sense that if
somewhere over the course of the various
escapades or the time that tony stark
and captain america were both operating
that tony stark took a blood sample and
basically now oscorp has her hands on i
know it seems a little weird to believe
that tony stark would take a blood
sample of captain america but would it
really be weird as much as we loved tony
stark he was kind of a dick so it makes
perfect sense that he would steal a
sample of captain america's blood or the
very least shield got their hands on it
and when like iron man was hacking into
the shield servers and avengers one then
he basically copied the sample right the
data of the sample and now ozcorp
working with stark industries is
essentially trying to make new super
soldiers and then over some amount of
time some things happen what do you know
one of those spiders with the odds
formula bites miles morales boom then
you got miles more out of spider-man in
the mcu you'd obviously have to do a lot
of work and a lot of lead-up to that to
make that happen it's not something you
could just do in the next spider-man
movie after the events of spider-man 3.
you need to kind of work on that a
little bit but i think it's a cool
concept right because if they did that
right if they use spider-man 3 as a way
to kind of prepare us for the idea of
multiple versions of the same version of
spider-man existing temporarily or even
permanently in the same landscape while
they're facing off against some kind of
threat then it wouldn't be that hard for
us to accept that miles morales exists
in the marvel cinematic universe and at
the same time spider-man into the
spider-verse miles morales is out there
doing his own thing because by this
point we've just kind of generally
accepted yeah it's entirely possible
you've got multiple versions of the same
character running around the multiverse
loki did a great job of giving us that
concept right we generally accepted it i
mean we all wanted to really figure out
whether or not it was a crocodile or an
alligator loki i think that's still
being debated i don't know enough and to
be honest i don't care enough to look it
up but one way or another we all love
the idea of there being like multiple
versions of the same character appearing
in different forms similar forms across
the multiverse and while miles morales
is not peter parker he is another person
bitten by a radioactive spider that
gains what are in effect powers that are
similar to peter parker's in some ways
and identical to others and starkly
different than other ways than that
right miles morales has like his venom
blast right he's got the ability to make
himself invisible and then he's got all
the other powers of spider-man to go on
top of that right so it's a cool concept
and it's a cool idea this could
potentially lead into a much bigger
thing but again i want to know what you
guys think about this right you guys are
you guys kind of like i mean
it's cool but like it's a bit of a
stretch or you're just kind of like oh
snap son rob just flipped the script and
changed the game
yeah
let me know what you guys think down in
the comments section i doubt anybody's
reacting that way to the second part i'm
gonna be honest with you guys i kind of
imagine that like when you guys are
watching my videos you guys finish and
you're just kind of like cool
and like you go on and watch the next
video i would like to believe you guys
watch my videos and you're like yeah man
rob man i totally feel where you're
coming from man you just just
yeah you know you just get like super
amped up i don't know if that's true or
not i think it'd be awesome if it was
i'm sorry guys i get excited right i get
excited when i talk about stuff like
this it's fun to me it's exciting to me
i never care if i'm right i just allow
my imagination to go crazy and come up
with the most like insane theories
because it's fun right i just i just dig
it right i just dig that whole process
but regardless let me know you guys
think of this down in the comments
section thank you guys for watching and
i will catch you all later
peace